un año después de su elección la
situación es difícil para Emmanuel
macron no queremos tu reforma Qué es lo
que no entiendes después de meses este
conflictos por las pensiones y tensiones
con muchos franceses sus opositores
intentan capitalizar estas dificultades
lo sentimos distancia brutalidad
violencia institucional desprecio y
arrogancia
hoy solamente el 26% de los franceses se
dice satisfecho con el jefe de estado
una reducción de dos puntos con respecto
al mes pasado según este sondeo
siendo el primer presidente reelecto
después de la cohabitación Emmanuel
macron se mostró dudoso Desde los
primeros días de su segundo mandato se
tomó más de un mes en nombrar a una
nueva primera ministra Elizabeth después
de haber Aparentemente preferido durante
largo tiempo a la elegida de extrema
derecha Catherine en junio fracasa a la
hora de obtener una mayoría absoluta en
la asamblea nacional algunos de sus más
cercanos resultan derrotados para este
periodista existe una explicación
macron durante su primer mandato pensó
en su reelección esa era su obsesión
pero con respecto a lo que iba a hacer
después de dicha reelección no pensó
para nada y es por culpa de este vacío
que macron está en una situación tan
complicada es porque tomó malas
decisiones que su segundo mandato
comenzó mal y que ese segundo mandato
será extremadamente complicado la
reforma de las pensiones marcó La
Cúspide de este año con la utilización
del artículo 49.3 y la ruptura con los
sin dicatos y una parte de la opinión
pública estas reformas aceptada
evidentemente no no entre dos crisis en
el país Emmanuel macron volvió a
lanzarse a la escena internacional con
Joe biden en la casa blanca o más
recientemente en China con el presidente